The Chinese market has long been a goldmine
for many German companies, with high-end car
makers like Audi and Mercedies making an ever
larger share of their profits here.
But the BDI Federation for German Industy
claims the Chinese market is far from a level
playing field.
The business lobby accuses Beijing of using
a combination of protectionism, price dumping,
and state-subsidies to bolster China's economy
and cement the central government's control.
The development of a free market isn't on
Beijing's agenda.
The central government is trying to expand
the communist party's control of the economy
and civil society and that's become more apparent
in the last three years.
There is also growing concern that China's
shopping tour of buying controlling shares
of German high-tech companies like robotics
manfaturer Kuka could soon lead to a strategic
disadvantage for Europe.
In their report the BDI is calling on Berlin
to take action to make the economies of Germany
and Euopre more resiliant.
Among the demands: increased scrutiny of China's
state-support for firms that compete with
European companies and more oversight of Chinese
acquisitons.
But the BDI also says western countires must
do more to defend their lead in techonology
Of course we need to do our own homework and
increase our own competitveness by investing
more in infrastructure and education including
research by expanding the EU's research budget.
The BDI also believes EU members must close
ranks to insure China does not eventually
gain
a competitive edge
in tehcnology.